[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'ancient
parler sport l'émission à ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux de sport local
c'est l'été il fait beau il fait chaud
et c'est bientôt les vacances mais
rassurez vous nos chroniqueurs qui
commenteront dans cette émission
l'actualité sportive du département
n'ont pas encore enfilé leurs maillots
de bain est mis à leur crème solaire ils
sont déterminés à donner le meilleur
d'eux mêmes avant de prendre une pause
estivale bien méritée présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite on le
surnomme dans cette émission le
gladiateur qu'il fasse beau qu'il pleuve
qu'il vente ou qu'il neige est toujours
prêt à descendre dans l'arène pour faire
mordre la poussière à ses ennemis
je ne présente plus pierre chevallier du
rugby-club de versailles est avec nous
comment allez vous pierre c'est chaud
forme bonheur c'est bon c'est l'été
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit en
pleine forme alors nous allons parler de
l'open de france de golf allait ravir à
vivre plein d'avis on est en plein dans
la balle blanche dans une un début
d'activité d'actualité qui va durer
jusqu'à fin septembre c'est top
cet homme c'est beau c'est ça on passe à
ma gauche un musique c'est un monument
de cette émission il était là lors de la
première il est encore là aujourd'hui
pour faire simple c'est le john mcenroe
de la répartie le rocky balboa des
débats vous allez passer
avec l'huile agence fissures mustapha
larfaoui le président d'honneur de
l'étoile sportive de trappes bonjean
michael merci pour la présentation comme
toujours quand tu as d'ailleurs les gens
n'attendent que ça c'est la présentation
qu'ils préfèrent je vais faire dans les
jambes et ouais rester mais moi je parle
on l été approche quand vous n'êtes pas
encore en vacances si jamais jamais
jamais jamais de vacances n'ont jamais
on repasse à ma droite musicale fait son
grand retour dans cette émission et
quelques semaines d'absence pour ceux
qui ne la connaissent pas encore c'est
un peu la chuck norris de la pole dance
ce sport qui mêle danse et acrobatie
autour d'une barre à la fédé figure que
personne ne peut réaliser notre
ambassadrice de charme
hélène de la grange nous fait le plaisir
de venir sur cette émission pendant une
heure cette menace
we say say say conceptuel bien très bien
je suis ravie d'être revenue je parlerai
de ce petit sur nos musées à mes élèves
elle oeuvre également elle rigole
combien je pense que juste après
l'émission à leur passe de l'autre côté
à musique qui nous vient tout droit de
plaisir on le surnomme dans cette
émission le zorro et binoy après
plusieurs émissions d'absence le vengeur
masqué est de retour pour nous jouer des
mauvais tours l'incroyable le valeureux
le cavalier international raul contre l
autre et est avec nous bonjour à ulrich
à elle quand allez-vous super comme
d'habitude comme d'habitude réservé aux
entrées dans l'été tout se passe très
bien on va voir sa vraie mission nous
allons reste trop vite sur la
présentation je trouve qu'on passe
combinera passé une heure sur la série
d'incidents c'est un vrai talent ça
aurait à l'inversé lancer la spark
attend ça va chercher le meilleur sérum
et où à chaque émission c'est sûr bien
position c'est un vrai boulot cette
semaine deux semaines quasiment sur la
présentation je trouve qu'on va trop
vite représentation doivent aller encore
plus vite à mustapha et on va rester sur
la présentation alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons nous
intéresser à tony yoka est à sa
cinquième victoire chez les
professionnels nous ouvrirons également
un débat sur le sport et la politique
les deux sont-ils incompatibles mais
avant de développer ces thèmes nous
allons parler de golf et de l'open de
france
les drapeaux sont hissés les greens
coupé au millimètre ce jeudi 22 28 juin
à la 102e édition de l'open de france a
débuté sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
pendant quatre jours un plateau
d'exception va s'affronter on retrouvera
notamment justin thomass le numéro 2
mondial sera quand il sera considéré
comme le favori de l'épreuve pour sa
première sur le tournoi l'américain veut
gagner pour préparer le futur ryder cup
qui se tiendra sur le même parcours une
décision qui pourrait ravir le capitaine
de l'équipe américaine jim fric on
écoute et il a compris qu'il y avait des
choses à mettre en place des stratégies
à faire pour préparer notre corps et
notre jeu à la saison évidemment la
ryder cup pour moi mais il y à d'autres
tournois jusqu'à la ryder cup
j'ai essayé de faire le meilleur
planning pour maints pas du côté des
français le numéro un tricolore
alexander à lévis 27 ans va tenter de
décrocher sa qualification pour la ryder
cup 2018 en remportant son premier open
de france pour mettre toutes les chances
de son côté le varois analysé le
parcours on écoute sa réaction
on a passé six heures sur le parcours a
vraiment essayé de le planifier au mieux
de bêtes plein de stratégie et pouvoir
bien m'entraîner a joué intelligemment
ce parcours il ya également sur le
parcours les deux espagnols john rabe et
sergio garcia ou encore le fantasque ang
et anglais ian poulter plus de quarante
mille personnes sont attendues pour
observer à ses champions quand on voit
ce plateau d'exception et cet
enthousiasme peut-on se dire que cet
open de france et le plus beau de
l'histoire c'est la question sur ce
thème est ce que c'est le plus beau de
l'histoire
oui oui vous êtes unanimes sur la
question pierre chevallier pourquoi pour
trois raisons il est y est juste avant
la guerre chômage et que j'en viens
on vient et j'ai vu le j'ai vu le golf
national frémir au début de cet open et
puis c'est de bonne augure pour la ryder
cup par là pour quelques raisons la
première c'est que sportivement on a
rarement eu un plateau aussi relevé avec
déjà avec quelques arrêts des américains
présents la plupart des françaises qui
arrose français présents des onglets des
européens des espagnols et tout ce qui
vient de se tester hommage national à le
battre au savon le avant la ryder cup
techniquement aussi serre sur le terrain
je connais le stationnaire depuis
quelques années pour l'avoir joué il a
martyrisé plus d'une fois et là et dans
des conditions absolument fabuleuse pour
les pour les joueurs professionnels pour
vous envoyer des amateurs comme nous sur
le sur le terrain je pense qu'on prend
un bouillon au monumental
parce qu'en plus il est il a été rendu
un petit peu plus étroits les lignes des
greens sont évidemment extrêmement
rapide donc c'est vraiment extrêmement
bien préparés pour les pour les pros et
évidemment à l'horizon la ryder cup puis
la dernière raison c'est je pensais en
terme d'organisation
puisqu'on est dans une année de ryder
cup c'est une répétition générale donc
il ya un peu plus de moyens qui sont mis
sur différents sur différents aspects
donc pour ces trois pour ces trois
raisons là oui ça ressemble à l'hymne au
moins une très belle édition voir la
plus belle édition qui était de donner
au moins au golf national puis qui sait
jouer ailleurs dans l'histoire mais sur
le golf national s'est en tout cas ça
promet d'être une très belle et vous
êtes d'accord avec pierre choyés moi
j'ai pas eu la chance de me rendre mais
je peux que je peux que confirmer le
propos de pierre à savoir que la
forcément pour 2018 là avec la ryder cup
la france est misé sur le toit du monde
du golf mondial
donc tous les tous les projecteurs sont
et tous les moyens sont mis en place en
france pour que pour que l'événement
soit d'une envergure sans précédent
vaut mieux pas mieux du fait des acteurs
pas mieux du fait de la technique pas
mieux du fait d'être la question c'est
est-ce que c'est le plus beau de
l'histoire pour ça que je dis pas mieux
parce que c'est le plus beau c'est ce
qu'ils ont dit mes camarades et pour les
avoir bien écouté mes crèmes
contrairement à vous faut savoir bien
écouté j'ai cru comprendre qu'ils
avaient dit que c'était le plus beau de
tous et je confirme par les acteurs par
la technique par les installations puis
encore une fois on a on a en vue la
ryder cup mais mais moi il ya un autre
argument pour lequel je considère que
c'est le plus beau de toute façon c'est
que c'est lui qui est en présence c'est
à dire qu'à partir du moment il est là
devant nous ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est
par définition toujours le dernier
comme c'est la plus belle coupe du monde
de football qu'on aura cette année comme
c'est ça sera le meilleur ryder cup
qu'on n'ait jamais eu de tout les temps
je m'intéresse toujours aux événements
présents j'aime bien de passer j'aime
bien regarder un peu ce qui s'est passé
mais pour le coup je reste fille je
reste fixé quand même toujours sur
l'avant donc je souscris techniquement
sur ce qui a été dit mais en plus c'est
lui qui est à venir c'est sûr qu'on va
vivre donc par définition et même et
toujours en admiration et on est en
attente de ce qui se passe à côté de
chez nous avec des personnes
potentiellement qu'on connaît qu'on a pu
croiser et c'est là c'est juste là on
peut rajouter aussi qu'il ya un
phénomène notre activité qui est assez
impressionnant et par rapport aux
éditions précédentes le sas que les
cadres 4 3 ou 4 précédentes le public a
répondu présent ce matin au lay your
eyes quarante mille personnes la
configuration à la compétition qu'on va
par jour voilà une configuration à ryder
cup c'est jusqu'à soixante mille
personnes jour ce qui sera la plus
grosse affluence sur une ryder cup dans
l'histoire mais ce matin ce matin à
guyancourt il y avait il y avait
énormément de monde
ares est vrai que avec une partie la
partie de lévis de fleetwood qui est de
thomas ce qui paraît à 8 heures il y
avait déjà du monde dieu du monde à 8
heures et ça fait plaisir à voir c'est
gros il ya du monde sur les buts du
national mais puisque l'émission cession
par les sports de plus en plus les
événements attirent du monde terre que
la la coupe du monde de football attire
de plus en plus de téléspectateurs de
plus en plus de monde sont dans les
stades de plus en plus pour l'album de
francs de plus en plus j'espère pour la
ryder cup
mais c'est vrai également quand on a des
grandes compétitions équestres quand on
a des compétitions encore une fois
qu'ils sont bien organisés
de plus en plus on a du monde à aller
vers le sport alors quand même c'est
pour ça que je fais un point un point
particulier sur votre émission c'est que
votre émission elle par le sport elle
attire du monde vers le sport mais elles
restent quand même sur l'idée que le
sport c'est important
d'abord pour son physique à son
bien-être et là une petite question
quand même on aurait pu espérer voir un
tiger woods un joueur ultra médiatique
ou à rory mcilroy
on l'a pas sur cet open de france on a
justin thomas ce qui est certes
talentueux mais qui n'est pas forcément
connus du très grand public
c'est peut-être une déception oui après
évidemment qu'avec tiger woods autres
grands joueurs ccc des têtes d'affiché
normes qui ont un côté glamour qui ont
le côté qui attire vraiment le regard
qui attire du public et c'est maintenant
c'est quand même on a quand même des
joueurs qui sont talentueux on a des
espoirs aussi donc c'est une autre façon
d'intéresser c'est vraiment une autre
peut-être moins tape à l'oeil mais mais
mais plus dans la découverte du sport
sur la table pour qu'ils viennent tout
simplement
il avait un autre rendez vous en
parallèle on va chercher là où il ya
peut-être une déception là dessus sur
d'ailleurs mousse qui n'est pas mieux
il n'est pas venu depuis 1994 et un
championnat du monde junior amateur dans
ces cas là j'imagine que c'est aussi un
problème de dotation je pense qu à
partir de calendrier dotation votation
était quand même à certains neurones
un sportif de haut niveau accompli est
indéniablement un homme d'affaires donc
et fait des choix financiers ça c'est ce
serait mensonger et hypocrite que de le
négliger donc j'ai mais j'imagine que
c'est c'est aussi la réalité du sport de
haut niveau vous dire qu'on le verra à
la ryder cup on le verra en septembre
soit vice-capitaine voir éventuellement
il peut être encore encore les dans les
clous pour être joueur bon c'est plus
difficile mais on le verra de toute
façon et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour le golf mondial français d'abord
mais pour le golf mondial
mais pour pour finir sur ce sujet c'est
un plateau qui est homogène dire qu'on a
on a quand même pas mal de tête
d'affiché a effectivement pas tous les
porte drapeaux mais on a quelques
américains quelques repères bien placé
des espagnols les français sont tout
cela est d'ailleurs en force lors du
puissant sauf du but je les ai faits de
santé qui a mis sa carrière entre sa
saison entre parenthèses
mais l'arrière il y affrontera pas
rentable le théâtre de tête la sucent
révélateur mais sait on à il ya
suffisamment de monde et d'ailleurs tout
le public répond présent
en tout cas ça frémit ça frémit
fortement pour cette année 2,9
dernière question sur cette thématique
est ce que vous avez ce sentiment pierre
chevalier de santé un engouement plus
grand en verre avec les médias avec tout
ce qui est retombé médias dans dans les
journaux et sur les plateaux télé ça
vient c'est à dire qu'en gros c'est un
travail de longue haleine qui avec a
démarré pour le golf qui a froid une
dizaine d'années aux moyens on va dire
l'open de france a déjà participé
largement à pouvoir attraper quelques
champions qui viennent qui vient
d'accueillir en cours et c'est vrai que
ça de ça donne ça donne un certain de
retombées médiatiques on est encore loin
du compte
quand par rapport à des sports grand
frère comme le foot ou le tennis par
exemple on est vraiment très loin du
compte mais sur une année où on a
on a justement deux événements majeurs
en france en ile de france que sur
l'open et la rider on a une occasion
unique de frapper fort
et puis avec un horizon 2024 avec les jo
qui seront jouées au même endroit on a
une fenêtre que qu'on n'a jamais eue
quand on aura sûrement l'ont sûrement
jamais justement pas parler d'eux
on continue à parler de l'open de france
de golf si l'édition de cette annonce
cette année s'annonce superbe l'édition
de l'année prochaine pourrait faire
redescendre sur terre tous les
organisateurs sont en plusieurs rumeurs
le sponsor principal à chênée devrait se
retirer dès 2019 pour les raisons
financières un an plus tôt que prévu ce
qui pourrait avoir des conséquences sur
le statut de rolex series de l'épreuve
mais pour l'instant rien n'est confirmé
à nous avons eu l'interview de paul
hermitage le directeur du golf national
de saint quentin en yvelines
c'est une rumeur nous en est concentré
et focalisé sur cette année en a une
magnifique météo jusqu'à dimanche soir
on a des préventes biais fantastique
donc on va laisser la rumeur à la rumeur
et puis vous posera la question là où il
faudra alors le tournoi qui était dotée
de 3 millions d'euros dont 500000 euros
pour le vainqueur a vu sa dotation
passer à 7 millions de dollars en 2010
est la question sur ce thème le tournoi
est il menacé
pour paul hermitage on ne sait pas
encore vous êtes partagés ont fait un
petit duel entre moustapha et pierre
chevalier mustapha est ce qu'il est mais
là c'est ce ce trois îles pour moi il ne
l'est pas on vient de le dire à
l'instant il ya de plus en plus de
d'événements qui sont ultra métiers dits
médiatisé et en plus c'est des éléments
qui s'auto qui s'autoalimente c'est à
dire qu'on a de plus en plus de télé qui
s'intéressent au golf qui est rôle
relativement bien télégénique
on a plus en plus de monde donc du coup
ça alimente les télés les télés alimente
le monde donc par définition ça ne peut
qu'attirer du sponsoring
c'est juste le phénomène entre
guillemets de business qui fonctionne
comme ça donc pour moi il peut pas être
menacé
c'est un tel événement c'est quelque
chose qui est tellement ancrée
maintenant qui est en devenir
qui est en train de progresser comme on
l'a dit tout à l'heure par définition le
sponsoring suivra et le public et les
médias donc il peut pas être menacé
simplement on a un partenaire à mon avis
qui doit être en train de négocier sur
pareil on est dans la négociation ici
c'est si on parlait sport souvent
cession par les peaux nyon les choses
vont souvent de pair à ce niveau là donc
là on on est purement dans une négo
voilà donc le sponsor dis moi il me faut
peut-être je sais pas mais il ya des
doléances au niveau du sponsoring
après il peut avoir un souci lui-même de
pognon et auquel cas ils préfèrent se le
mettre ailleurs
mais moi je suis totalement à l'aise si
c'est pas lui ça sera un autre menace et
non ils peuvent un autre contrat de
sponsoring
cette envergure là il peut y avoir bien
sûr est fragile et il ya des tas de
marques qui sont intéressés par des
événements de ce niveau là d'autant plus
que quand on disait tout à l'heure
merci pour le grand frère des sports
frères entre l'entrée guillemets il ya
très peu d'événements pendant que pour
les amateurs de golf y en a peu au
regard du nombre de matches de football
en regard du nombre de matches d'autres
d'autres sports on tienne à tellement
peu que ça se concentre pour moi y
aurait un intérêt ce que ce soit le même
qui reste par définition
auquel cas il serait plus menacées voire
à d'autres de rentrer bien sûr il y aura
des entrants tout cas c'est le pari que
je fais c'est pour ça que le seul la
seule menace qui peut peser avec le
retrait déchaîné c'est ça peut être le
ou à dire une volée médiatique que si le
tournoi des plus estampillé rolex series
avec sa dotation
on risque de ne plus avoir sa place les
meilleurs tournois européens dans le
calendrier mondial où les meilleurs
jouent donc là on aura peut-être plus
les américains des gens qu'on n'en a pas
forcément beaucoup chaque année on en
aura peut-être plus
mais le tourneau masse on aura plus
viendra plus fort c'est vous parce que
ça sera plus sur ses tablettes
importante de l'année
en revanche le tournoi qui fait son
102ème anniversaire cette année est un
des plus est le plus vieux d'europe
continentale à une certaine histoire une
certaine assise
il a inscrit aussi l'histoire du sport
du golf amateur et notamment avec un
système de qualification de tous les
deux tout les amateurs et des pros
français qui pourrait à ce moment-là
revenir si s'il n'était plus estampillé
raulhac series il ya plein de moyens qui
existeront en dehors de trouver un
nouveau sponsor qui ne mettra peut-être
pas 7 millions sur la table mais
peut-être un petit peu moins et il
suffira largement à organiser un beau
tournoi il ya plan moyen de faire en
sorte que ce tournoi ne meurt pas parce
que il a une histoire il a une âme il a
désormais un stadium fantastique qui va
être reconnue mondialement par l'open
par la ryder cup et par légions en 2024
donc encore une fois on a on a quelques
belles années devant donc vous êtes
plutôt optimiste plutôt optimiste oui la
chênaie à priori à miser pour voir sur
deux années à acheter les deux années
juste avant la ryder cup
ça ressemble vraiment un coup de pub en
étant présents jusqu'à jusqu'à la ryder
cup
une fois la rigueur cathérine terminé on
prend ses cliques et ses claques qui
vont passer à autre chose
peut-être trouver un autre partenaire
sur ce théâtre international
buster de du sport on l'a vu également
dans l'automobile un moment donné il ya
eu des intérêts qu'ils ont été menacés
dans le sport automobile en france se
sont retirés mais à un moment donné la
france reste une place importante
et pour ça je peux pas imaginer qu'ils
soient menacés maintenant c'est un coup
dur sont des vacances un coup dur raul
guti est partagée qui vous a convaincu
pierre ou safari
je rejoins pire parce que sont
finalement il a répondu il a répondu
rouge et puis pour finalement quand même
avoir une
un propos assez assez partagés je pense
que quand on est les événement de cette
envergure c'est quand même une
plateforme médiatique non négligeable
donc ça peut intéresser d'autres firmes
que la chesnaie je crois en plus que
c'est des questions que ceux qui se sont
posés on en a un en avant dans les
médias maintenant mais il ya des
articles sur la chesnaie déjà depuis
mars 2000 depuis le mois de mars d'une
dette de 100 milliards d'euros
donc c'est un groupe qui est déjà en
difficulté donc j'imagine que il ya déjà
une somme de 100 milliards de dettes
bien ça c'est dans les médias je
donnerai donc moi qu'on prend l'exemple
de l'équitation pendant pendant
cinquante ans le circuit coupe du monde
était sponsorisé par rolex
quand ils se sont séparés ça ça parait
il ya une une grosse hécatombe mais y
est médiatique et puis finalement dès
l'année de l'année qui a suivi le
partenariat avec l'eau jean s'est très
très bien passé le et le circuit n'a
fait qu'évoluer donc c'est changer un
peu une certaine organisation un peu une
tradition travailler toujours avec les
mêmes c'est ça voilà donc si c'est un
taux d'habitude non non mais en fait
c'est cesser
s'échanger des idées c'est la deuxième
année des partenaires cp historique
d'accor et il devait rester une année de
plus il a signé pour trois ans à la base
ça change quelques données justement il
n'ya pas peut-être ce côté ryder cup qui
se déroule au mois de septembre
et du coup le groupe a enchaîné je
trouve pas forcément d'intérêt à
poursuivre l'aventuré
juste derrière bercy ici on prend si on
prend le point de raul cessé il ya déjà
une dette donc on a annoncé on a un
petit peu cassé le porte monnaie pour
s'offrir le le parcours de l'open de
france pour la ryder cup 2018 une femme
il faut qu'elle ait passé un super tour
à tour a trouvé ça choquant à mustapha
de quoi que que le groupe h est né
quitte à l'open de france avant la fin
de son contrat
non c'est pour ça que je disais tout à
l'heure il ya rien de menaçant pour le
tournoi ça sera à eux qu'ils
continueront 6 y trouvent un intérêt ça
sera d'autres qui viendront deux fils
parce qu'il ya un intérêt pas
suffisamment de choses mais est ce que
sait faire peur est ce que sait faire
plein tenant maintenant c'est pareil
c'est contractuel donc ils se sont
engagés pour trois ans donc je peux pas
imaginer qu'il se retire avant pour ce
qui est des clauses de pénalités enfin
je veux dire moi je connais pas le
contraire mais une amie ça risque
vraiment un jeu de poche de vie on est
en pleine négociation joue fourbit ses
armes
maintenant rien ne me choque parce que
encore une fois faut bien faut bien voir
que le sport cherche ses marques
donc c'est le sport qui courent après
les marques et les marques ont besoin de
s'adosser aux sports donc c'est des
compagnons de route dont rien ne me
choque ce qui me choquerait c'est qu'on
ne parle plus du sport amateur ce qui
n'est pas le cas de tv 78 et je le dis
mais c'est d'accord mais craint pas
voilà et en ce moment c'est pas
forcément que le football dernière
question que doit faire la fédération
française de golf à votre avis à raul
ils doivent tout de suite trouver un
nouvel investisseur pour garder le
statut de rolex series pour l'année
prochaine à votre avis des événements
comme ça de toute façon ce qu'est ce que
la d'abord je suis assez surpris de la
question parce que je pensais pas que
que sur des événements aussi aussi je
pensais que c'était plusieurs ressorts
du privé que la fédération n'avait pas
vraiment de
de la fédération s'il ya des choix
abondant et le terrain de golf
la vitrine ils veulent frimer mois la
fédération intervient surtout quand les
blés de dandé venant des commandants des
compétitions où les golfeurs représente
par équipes lors ces cahiers etc
mais c'est prévu fille qui réglementait
qui règlemente le jeu mais je sais pas
s'il y avait une chance sur les jeunes
et puis qui rendent dans les contrats
c'est le sait le goal des licenciés
c'est le goal des golfeurs français est
donc en tant que propriétaire il signe
le contrat pour le pen il doit chercher
tout de suite un nouveau sponsor comme
une connaissance profiter ils vont
profiter de cette élite de cette
année-là de cette édition 2010 8 et là
son 2e ils ont bien assez de temps pour
réagir juste avant la ryder cup et pour
l'édition 2009 une dette il s'agit pas
pour audi ce groupe est certes un budget
parce qu'une dette amendé il faut aussi
retrouver des clients font retrouver un
business modèle qui fonctionne c'est pas
forcément ému a précisé
[Musique]
mustapha on passe maintenant notre
rubrique résultats nous allons
maintenant nous intéresser à la boxe en
illinois a brillé ce samedi à 23 juin le
champion olympique des poids lourds tony
yoka originaires de chanteloup les
vignes a remporté samedi au palais des
sports de paris son cinquième combat
chez les professionnels en dominant
l'anglais dévide haleine par arrêt de
l'arbitré à la 10e reprise le français
de 26 ans gagne pour la quatrième fois
avant la limite et victoire acquise en
plein scandale sur ses à 3 notes aux
trois contrôles antidopage seront
effectués avec cette frasque le chouchou
les français après les jo commence à
subir ces premières grosses critiques
la question sur ce thème toin tony yoka
est il en train de perdre l'appui du
public
oui ou non c'est quoi c'est oui vers les
séries non merci oui vous êtes unanime
et encore
et là j'ai droit je comprends pas cette
image
il représente quand même certaines
règles etc et je comprends pas en fait
où est l'intérêt de ne pas se présenter
ça peut remettre en cause ses résultats
son classement sont le fait qu'ils
soient supportés par tant de personnes
enfin jeu
pour moi oui oui je pense qu'il ya quand
même et même par rapport au sport par
rapport aux autres aux autres sportifs
du même voilà en boxe qui osent se
soumettent et aux contrôles etc
je ne vois pas pourquoi lui ou ne le
fait pas c'est comme essayer un sujet de
la boxe elle avait répondu oui également
sinon se tenir au cap-vert l'appui du
public
c'est une addition de meuf acteurs pour
le public un peu plus large et pas
forcément puristes de boxe bat
effectivement par le le cetc une son
côté un peu irrévérence par rapport à
ses obligations qui sont évidemment le
fruit de deux du de sa médiatisation par
rapport aux jeux olympiques on a quand
même fait un peu une bête de foire alors
que on sait très bien qu'en boxe par
différents ces différents réseaux de
sport en boxe quand on est champion
olympique on est loin du compte
finalement parce qu'on est on est sur le
on est sur le toit du monde amateur mais
a encore tout un parcours professionnel
ensuite à effectuer donc déjà c'est
vraiment finalement récupérer enfin
avoir une énergie autour de soi est un
média qui n'est pas du tout
représentatif de la prouesse sportive et
ensuite pour les gens qui sont un petit
peu plus pointu et qui est féru de boxe
le pareil le choix de ses combats tony
yoka c'est quelqu'un qui justement à
cause de son de sa vignette est très
protégée et on se questionne beaucoup
sur le choix de ses combats david allen
c'est surtout un sparring partner en
réalité c'est pas il est il est dans il
est dans le top 100 mondial certes mais
il passe plus son temps à se parer avec
les tyson fury anthony je suis là parce
que c'est un encaisseur incroyable que
qu'un vrai combattant
d'ailleurs le faut regarder le combat à
part quelques crochets du gauche qui
sont parfois passées et encore il peut
venir qu'avec ces deux mètres 1 il
tenait vraiment la distance
c'était tony yoka contrat ça que quand
on rencontre un sac de frappe quoi
pendant dix ans donc là oui
effectivement il va commencer à rentrer
dans une tourmente
c'est pas qu'il devrait effectivement il
des idées bars et ses débuts il ya que
ça il a que cinq combats à son actif
mais cyril leonet c'est un combat
intéressant la respectable mais sinon il
ya quelque chose d'un petit peu spécial
dans ce
soit il est surprotégé sais pas pourquoi
j'ai du mal à comprendre chez séché ces
jeunes champions c'est sûrement pour ça
la désormais de la manière dont il ne se
soustraient à leurs obligations ils ont
ils ont attiré la lumière à eux ils à ce
titre olympique derrière après il ya le
côté privé aussi qui prend un petit peu
le pas normal normale pour tous les
sportifs qui sont titrés et puis les
règles les règles sont rappelés sont
connus et il sent il s'en extrait alors
qu'il arrive qu'elle se sait surveillé
est désormais en plus là où c'est pour
ça que je réponds oui c'est que c'est
qu'il acquiert avec ce titre olympique
une image d'icône d'exemple pour les
pour les gamins boxeur ou pour les
gamins sportif d'une manière générale et
raté oublier des contrôles antidopage ça
met automatiquement un peu de suspicion
par dessus ça et ça ça froisse
l'exemplarité et l'image que l'on
souhaiterait avoir chez ses jeux ses
sportifs internationaux l'impression que
l'année dans une génération qui a besoin
de se faire remettre un peu en place
avec une espèce d'autorité avec une
sanction un peu et on a vraiment cette
impression que soit il ya peut-être un
réel problème
qui fait qu'il va pas au contrôle soit
voilà qu'il a besoin qu'on impose enfin
peut-être son entraîneur qui devrait lui
mettre la limite peut-être mais
l'entraîneur le pauvre il fait face il
fait face à tellement de 2
on est en 2010 8 kg dire le poids du
média sur le sport les rock stars qu'on
en fait alors que le l'entraînent
l'entraîneur c'est des gens qui doivent
qui va faire je pense et des dépressions
parce qu'ils ont ils sont face à des
managers et des gens qui ne comprennent
rien aux sports qui sont des financiers
qui ce qui des cameramans faut voir les
salles de boxe de tony hawk a déjà il
est parti aux états unis s'entraîner il
faut voir les le on connaît bien la
salle la salle de la team farrugia vous
voyez le clan très simple et très très
intimiste de cette salle de boxe qui
produit des champions d'europe
ce côté un petit peu authentique il y a
des salles de boxe avec des projecteurs
ils sont faits par des spectateurs des
ça prend une tournure qui est
complètement en décalage avec le sport
et comment on comment peut-on continuer
à en faire des guerriers si derrière il
ya toute une des obligations et des dés
et plein de facteurs qui les écartent de
leur performance donc ça en fait des
gens avec avec avec un esprit
complètement perturbés et qu'ils n'ont
pas sa défense mais comment il a 26 ans
en plus il est jeune belle autorité à
mon avis c'est pas forcément
l'entraîneur ou le coach je pense que
finalement ça va être
malheureusement la fédération qui va
arriver avec le poing sur la table dans
un environnement dans lequel en disant
on arrête et les sanctions ou alors
c'est maintenant et c'est à face à peut
lui faire du bien d'être sanctionnés à
tony yoka passe chez ba ça lui fera du
bien à lui parce que c'est jamais bon de
se faire sanctionner après tout il
pourrait l'éviter en plus mais ça fera
du bien la boxe ça fera du bien aux
sports en général ça fera du bien à
l'exemplarité un moment donné il ya des
contrôles antidopages convient dans ce
qu'on a changé d'époque
le dopage le dopage on l'a connu dans
d'autres sports on a vu les ravages que
ça fait sur le plan sur le plan des
athlètes eux-mêmes et en même temps les
dégâts que ça fait dans la société et
dans le sport en général ça fera du bien
évidemment à la boxe il serait mon ado p
non c'est bien présente mais justement
alors il l'est pas c'est juste cette
suspicion par définition quand on
s'extrait encadrement donné il ne l'est
pas et surtout pas c'est pas ici qu'on
va dire i feel et non plus c'est juste
qu'on sont soustraits on se soustraient
pas au dopage
on se soustraient aux contrôles
antidopage c'est pas la même chose ce
serait au contrôle c'est pas se dire
être dopé simplement je comprends pas
pourquoi on s'extrait des règles alors
après moi la question que je me pose
c'est est-ce que c'est justement parce
que il vient de l'olympisme
par définition le sport amateur le
sommet du sport amateur ville
relativement meilleure qu'il ya un
énorme malaise autour de lui et pas dire
clean
peut-être qu'il veut se bat peut 10 et
le bad boy de la boxe aucun randonnée
c'est le mental des règles je mens
extrait je rentre dans un sirh dans un
cycle est dans un cercle de gens parce
que la boxe est un peu sulfureux aussi
donc il faut rester au fond des
aspérités
je sais pas je crois pas je crois pas
question se soustraient à se soustraire
à l'intérêt du public elle et on on
vienne de toucy réponse dire que par le
passé par cet oubli là et partout alors
cette attitude là si c'est vraiment si à
mon lycée il s'est soustrait à ce genre
de parce que c'est un grand qui me plaît
c'est pas forcément nous en tous les cas
moi je suis pas un fan fan de boxe
j'aime bien regarder de temps en temps
par exemple des blockbusters de la même
façon des combats importants vivre
résumé titres olympiques par exemple
c'est ce que je fais mais à un moment
donné il ya peut-être un public où on a
envie de des fois dans le foot on le
trouve si ça un des mecs qui veulent
montrer qu'ils soient un peu bad boy
aussi je ne sais pas c'est un
positionnement je comprends par dior
enfin du ring chevallier on passe
maintenant notre rubrique focus
[Musique]
un autre yvelinois été sur le devant de
la scène sportive ce dimanche 24 juin en
aviron le versailles et thomas baruch a
décroché une belle à quatrième place en
finale avec son coéquipier pierre loing
en deux de couple poids léger lors d'une
manche de coupe du monde à linz en
autriche
ils ont été devancés par les équipages
italiens norvégien et belges les
satisfactions sont grandes pour les deux
français qui n'avaient jamais concouru
ensemble en compétition internationale
on écoute la réaction par téléphone de
lévis noah à thomas baruch première
finale ensemble
pareil quand même vachement positive
même si on est les premiers à être déçus
et frustrés de faire quatre plutôt que
pour te voilà il ya près d'une seconde
avec la médaille avec la troisième place
on veut rep et médailles
on va première sortie internationale que
bordeaux était fier sur orbite abl
l'équipage français termine donc
quatrième de cette course après avoir
été deuxième pendant plus de la moitié
de l'épreuve
la question sur ce thème est ce que
c'est une déception de finir quatrième
quand on entend toute cette histoire
oui non oui sévère c'est toujours cette
question
oui c'est vert rouge c'est non un petit
duel entre hélène et raul
hélène je pense que c'est toujours une
déception ne pas être sur un podium
quand on va par là donc c'est pour ça
que je réponds oui maintenant leur
première
concernant leur première course et puis
en équipe vraiment ensemble
le résultat est quand même tout à fait
honorable donc la déception elle est
juste ne pas être sur le podium
maintenant ils ont quand même montré
qu'ils étaient capables et je pense que
sur d'autres courses à 2 maintenant
voilà pour avoir vu que ensemble ça
fonctionne et ils peuvent quand même se
se rassurer se dire qu'ils ont quand
même assez bien assez performer sur 7
pour cela après c'est assez assez mitigé
ah oui nouveau binôme étape étape
internationale quatrième je ne vois pas
où la déception
non pour moi il ya une performance 6e j
imagine qu'ils se connaissent mais c'est
la première fois qu'ils s'illustrent à
l'international ensemble ne vois pas
comment je peux pas répondre plus de
manière plus précise que ça pour par les
arbres elle ne pourra pas les sports que
comme le faisait moustapha dia un euro
en france on a faim on parle toujours de
en france on tape on tape de toute façon
sur tout ce qui va jamais sur tout ce
qui va mal alors que quand il ya des
performances ok c'est au pied du podium
et c'est une quatrième place pour un
binôme qui est qui qui vient de se
constituer en plus il n'était pas loin
il était deuxième pendant la plupart la
majeure partie de la course
en gros il faut les encourager il c'est
hyper encourageant de voir d un binôme
comme ça qu'ils se constituaient ce
qu'ils vont rester ensemble c'est tout
ce qu'on leur souhaite en tout cas c'est
prometteur première finale ensemble
soyons positifs le verre à moitié plein
et ben bada on y va quoi moi ça va moi
je réponds toujours aux questions
la question c'est est-ce que c'est
décevant en tous les cas est ce que
c'est pour eux une déception la réponse
c'est oui quand on fait tout pour être
premier qu'on l'est pas c'est une
déception
donc je réponds à cette question par
l'affirmative ça me paraît évident mais
quand je vois le nombre de gamins déçus
par leurs performances par on le voit
bien la sortie des terrains la sortie de
vo2 de tous vos évènements la déception
sur ce qu'elle fait partie intégrante du
sport par des finissants c'est ce qui
permet de faire grandir
mais pour répondre à des questions c'est
évident et qu'on règle les images
termine derrière les maires des voix les
italiens et les belges
des images on a besoin de la photo parce
qu'on voit bien qu'ils n'en ont ils n'en
font pas grand chose donc oui pour
répondre à la question la réponse c'est
évident parce que la déception est
terrifiant quand on passe les
compétiteurs et combatif
donc là mais c'est inhérent aux sports
c'est un train de dire c'est
consubstantiel n'est ce pas raul est ce
que cette campagne est aussi peut-être
de rester caché
face à la concurrence cette quatrième
place au moi je pense pas parce que
comme je disais thomas baruch s'il avait
fait tout de suite une première ou la
seconde deuxième place la concurrence
les aura attendu crois pas parce que
c'est bon d'être là c'est bon d'être
douter quand on est sur une sur une
lancée
comment quand on quand on domine
généralement ainsi peu de pression
peut-être aussi vis-à-vis des médias
mais la réussite la réussite en supprime
de la pression à ok il ya des ya
certaines attentes ensuite mais je pense
que non on a eu la réussite créé la
réussite et je crois que tu arrives dans
une courbe dans une compétition en étant
redoutée
ça crée un ascendant donc pour objectif
d'aller aux jeux olympiques reproduire
mais il y avait un tout petit peu de ram
en plus c'était troisième sans le faire
exprès donc c'était quasiment une
stratégie d'être quatrième de cyprès
quand on veut pas se faire voir ans mais
carrément à l'écart pour le coup d'arrêt
d'oran on referme cette thématique on
ouvre notre page débats nous allons
maintenant nous intéressait dans notre
débat au cyclisme les championnats de
france sur route sont organisées jusqu'à
ce dimanche 1er juillet à
mantes-la-jolie 40000 spectateurs sont
attendus sur les routes pour le retour
de cette compétition dans les yvelines
il y aura six cent vingt et un coureurs
engagés pour résumer c'est l'un des
rendez vous de l'année pour le cyclisme
français petite différence pour cette
édition 2010 8 par rapport au précédent
rendez-vous le programme a été
bouleversée et notamment le dimanche
avec un départ à 8h45 pour l'épreuve en
ligne hommes au lieu de 11 heures
la raison la coupe du monde de football
les diffuseurs pense que cette
programmation est plus judicieuse pour
l'audimat la question sur ce thème est
ce que vous trouvez cela logique oui ou
non mais aussi la livre ou staff à
présent tout diable non il faut savoir
ce qu'on veut
autour de cette table j'entends souvent
des gens qui disent alors on n'a pas de
visibilité sur notre sport
en clair les mecs de la pétanque on voit
que des fous tu nous l'as pétanque on
aime la pétanque on ne voit pas la télé
pourquoi est-ce qu'on voit que des
footeux et pas dé paix tant que bref les
gens se plaignent de ne pas avoir de
visibilité sauf que quand il ya un
événement qui écrase comme moi c'est
juste qu'il ya un attrait et un attrait
pour le public qui arrêterait pour les
annonceurs ça va ça marche ensemble nos
parts définissant sa salle écrase donc
l'idée c'est de dire voilà il ya
possibilité de décaler pour être un peu
visible pape rhône ont l'opportunité
parce que par définition ils ne seront
pas du tout si c'était les scop et donc
l'idée pour moi par définition
judicieuse même si éventuellement
pourrait regretter que les gens ne
regardent pas plus le cyclisme que le
football ou qui ait pas plus de monde à
regarder le cyclisme que le football
à cette épreuve là peut-être quatre le
tour de folie pour le tour de france et
pour la coupe du monde dont ça se
télescopent
donc la question est de savoir si
effectivement on peut laisser encore un
peu de place aux quelqu'un on s'organise
et on le décale je le déplore cette idée
selon laquelle il ya beaucoup de gens
beaucoup d'argent dans le foot plus que
les autres sports parce que moi mon
histoire c'est le sport en général
mais il se trouve que faut pas être faut
pas être comment dire faut pas être
hypocrite craint un moment donné il ya
un sport qui écrase les autres il faut
trouver une des solutions donc pour moi
c'est une solution c'est une solution on
peut le déplorer
hélène vous êtes d'accord oui oui c'est
ce que je viens de dire je pense qu'il
faut être intelligent dans le dans
l'organisation pour ton monde puisse un
peu profité des différentes
manifestations
maintenant c'est assez compliqué de
décaler des matches
en coupe du monde je pense qu'un départ
à vélo c'est quand même un petit peu
plus j'emploie sur route voilà je pense
que voilà c'est c'est pas que c'est
moins prestigieux c'est que c'est plus
facile de le décaler d'une heure deux
heures voire même d'une journée
voilà donc également le tour de france a
aussi qui a été décalée d'une semaine
alors ça c'est un peu en avant des
puristes c'est pendant ce temps on est
dans un cas de figure le sport le plus
populaire occupe la scène médiatique
c'est le football déjà c'est le plus
populaire d'une manière générale la
rente air de coupe du monde il reste
plus grand chose donc c'est occuper
l'espace et les places qui restent là là
c'est à la fois intelligente et logique
de d'essayer comme il aime staff a peu
de pouvoir se garder une toute petite
part du gâteau dans ce qui reste est
d'avoir un tout petit peu de visibilité
au contraire dans une période où on
parle de sport en général pour reprendre
votre expression
donc on est dans une actualité sportive
assez riche très riche
si on arrive à caser tous les événements
il y aura de toute façon un tout petit
peu de retomber un peu plus important
que d'habitude sur le cyclisme par
exemple sur les championnats de france
que s'il avait été au milieu de nulle
part juste avant le tour de france et
et ce en coupe du monde de foot là au
moins l'aller les tous les médias et
tous les médias sportifs notamment parle
de sport ça peut être que positif quand
on arrive à trouver un créneau
mais là où tous à table on parle de
sport depuis tout à l'heure de d'audimat
mais on parle pas forcément des sportifs
justement parce que à 8h45 du matin
selon c'est sur une course c'est pas
forcément évident à raul en we say say
je m'attendais à si j'étais interrogé
justement soulevé un petit peu le
l'effet d'une des modifications de
calendrier sur le savoir si c'est un
effet direct sur le fonctionnement des
sportifs et sportives vont devoir se met
forcément plus tôt et pour pallier les
compléter s'il est si ce sont des choses
qui sont au prix qu'ils se sont prévues
à l'avance en amont voilà le on modifie
son rythme le les temps de repos le
sommeil etc
et c'est ça se met en place quand ça
doit se jouer dans des pays où
l'altitude est telle qu'il faut se
préparer différemment
comment on est vous le savez en en amont
vous y préparer et puis il ya une
deuxième chose c'est que tous les
coureurs sont soumis à la même même
rigueur certains on y vont tous levés
tôt donc amender sa départage plutôt
laisser toujours pourparlers organisés
ce convoi voir business les sportifs
tout sport sont amenés à changer leurs
horaires en fonction des heures de
diffusion donc les footballeurs le fond
les golfeurs de l'open sont ceux qui
partaient à 8h ce matin ils ont dû se
lever à 5 heures donc tous tous doivent
doivent s'adapter au mieux mieux les six
membres al'excuse mieux qu'ils restent
assez équitablement de tout le monde est
logé à la même enseigne
mieux mickaël vous connaissez la vallée
de chevreuse les cyclistes aussi c'est
pas à 17 heures qu'on les trouve c'est
plutôt le matin très tôt
c'est vers vers sait qui on est on a
fait en sorte on a senti qu'il souhaite
faire vite les aider c'est la télé qui a
voulu que les cyclistes se balade sur
les routes jusqu'à 17h30
parce que ça fait tout tout les après
midi au mont à la télé pour l'espion de
poule bref sinon les mecs c'est plutôt
très tôt qui font du vélo
donc ça m'avantage
pour moi c'est bien davantage ni un ni
un handicap c'est vrai pour tous le
groupe
c'est juste que pour la visibilité il
faut bien qu'on trouve une solution
comme comme tu le disais c'est compliqué
de bouger la coupe du monde mais la
coupe du monde j'entends tous les pays
j'entends pas le foot parce que beaucoup
de respect pour les cyclistes sport en
général donc on continue justement à
parler la coupe du monde de football des
milliers de supporters français vibre en
ce moment pour l'équipe de france c'est
pour les autres équipes également à
mustapha il n'y a pas que l'équipe de
france parmi eux des hommes politiques
on va aller du côté de la mairie et de
bois d'arcy ou philippe benassaya est un
grand fan de football et du psg à
regarder et pas grand chose c'est vrai
mais j'ai des choses qui me tiennent à
coeur notamment
eh bien je sais pas si je me faire des
amis mais le maillot du psg et le le le
le bal le drapeau du psg c'est une
vieille passion
alors pour lui la politique peut
s'apparenter aux sports écoutez son
analyse il ya des bons côtés dans les
deux des mauvais côtés dans les deux
jeux explique
il faut travailler en équipe en général
au foot et en politique mine de rien il
faut quand même travailler en équipe
on peut rien faire par exemple dans une
un projet municipal si on est pas tous
ensemble il ya aussi les individualités
dans le foot les avis des individualités
dans la politique aussi et puis à
l'obligation de résultat je pense que
c'est dans les deux cas il ya une
obligation de résultats tout en
respectant les uns et les autres la
question sur ce thème le sport et la
politique sont ils compatibles le sport
et la politique sont ils compatibles
vous votez oui ou non mustapha il faut
soumis livré ce soir y est donc non pas
qu elle cherchait pas le duel mustafar
vous avez vu quand même un peu hésité
ben oui parce que encore une fois c'est
là c'est la définition des mots c'est
compliqué quand on parle de politique on
bascule souvent donc côté politiciens
donc l'idée selon laquelle la politique
s'immisce dans le sport et c'est en
réalité le sport est compatible avec la
politique le sport est compatible avec
la vie en général puisqu'il c'est par
définition ce qui nous ce qui nous fait
du bien au corps et à l'âme donc
maintenant si on commence à faire le
lien entre les deux oui quand j'entends
cohn bendit parler foot et politique
versus mélenchon parler foot
par rapport vite par rapport aux
allemands par exemple et que la
politique rentre dans c dans ses
dimensions là ça pue ça où j'aime moi ça
me gêne clairement ça me gêne premier
point ça ça me gêne parce que si on
commence à dire les je suis content que
les allemands soient sortis parce que
merkel se disent oh là c'est juste que
je comprends pas c'est tellement
tellement irrévérencieux par rapport au
peuple allemand d'une part et par
rapport au foot en général et aux sports
donc ça me gêne parce que comme mehdi du
cours répond peut-être que le venezuela
aurait pu faire mieux et ses enfants ça
prend des proportions pas possible cette
dimension là me gèle ensuite la deuxième
dimension qui me gêne c'est en tant que
président d'honneur d'un club de foot de
sport c'est de voir autant de gens
utiliser le sport l'utiliser en tant que
club amateur c'est de dire il ya des
gens qui prennent les présidences pour
accéder à la mairie ce qu'ils veulent
réellement ceux qui ne le font pas pour
ça mais à qui on dit je pense qu'il a
une visée politique parce qu'ils
s'occupent d'un club de foot donc ce
mélange des gens me posent un vrai
problème parce que je considère qu'un ce
qui est important c'est quand on est
quand on est dans son objet le sport à
son objet l'objet c'est le bien-être
personnel donc le corps et l'esprit
sssa l'objet après c'est la technique du
sport qui rentrent en jeu donc le foot
la pratique des uns et des autres avec
des performances des résultats des
championnats mais ça se entre guillemets
c'est complètement dans son objet donc
ya pas de raison qu'on mélange
simplement je le dis aussi bah ouais
mais le problème c'est que ça fait
partie de la vie d'abord on s'en inspire
du foot parce que c'est des valeurs or
les valeurs du sport sont bonnes
également pour la politique pour la
jeunesse est il le dit dans son livre
c'est pour ça que je dis c'est très
compliqué comme questions politiques de
façon politique et politicienne ça me
pose un problème sortir de l'objet sport
pour en faire quelque chose quasiment un
intérêt personnel et politique ça me
gêne aussi maintenant que le sport
apporte ses valeurs parce que la société
en a besoin pour la citoyenneté pour
l'éducation de nos enfants
en ce sens là le sport est un prétexte
et donc c'est très très bon pour le
vivre ensemble par définition
virtualisés la formulation de la
question me pose un problème sur le côté
conte est compatibilité ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut rappeler aux dire c'est qu'il
ya un pouvoir absolument énorme sur sur
le
sur l'aspect populaire et du sport il ya
un bon résultat je me rappelle de 98
bien évidemment un bon résultat d'une
équipe nationale et ses essais et en
gagnant gagne trois points de confiance
pour les ménages et pour des années pour
les pour des mois entiers non ça jacques
chirac notamment par exemple par exemple
par exemple il ne connaissait pas les
noms il ne connaissait pas les noms des
joueurs de l'équipe de france mais il
était dans le dans le process général
ils sont dans son côté bonhomme et et
bon enfant et est extrêmement jovial 98
après ça ça emmené une vague une vague
de effet de bien-être avec bonhomie
jeune mustapha ses côtés récupération
c'est le mot c'est le mot assez le mot
parce que justement effectivement on se
place
on se replace on récupère à son propre
profit
localement ou nationalement les
résultats d'une équipe sportive
après on a on a quand même derrière la
bannière actuellement de l'équipe de
france on a on a quasiment toute la
population même ceux qui ne sont pas
grands fans de foot
on espère qu'ils vont aller le plus loin
possible quand ils font 0 0 contre le
danemark
havas après un match insipide on est
tous on est tous un petit peu sur notre
faim et on voudrait qu'ils fassent mieux
donc c'est le côté compatible me pose un
problème il ya automatiquement des
rapports des rapports et qui peuvent
être négatif ou positif vu le vu la
puissance la puissance populaire à la
puissance la puissance sur le sur le
mental et le moral que peut avoir le
tout sport sur la population française
par exemple
raul qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors
je vais soulever deux points le
promeneur c'est possible vous allez
voter vert oui parce que alors il est
évident que la pratique du sport elle
doit être complètement apple a politisé
sacem il n'y a pas de discussion là
dessus et surtout je effectivement je
dénonce ces prises de position par
intérêt et ses fausses implication des
politiques au sein du quelque chose de
quelque chose justement aussi sain et et
pure que le sport seul on va revoir un
cachet peut-être leur cachet pour le
sport et la politique sont évidemment
aux noix indissociables et encore plus à
l'échelle municipale puisque
on sait c'est un maire convoyés sur le
reportage parce que bell et les filières
sportives les fédérations sont des
institutions publiques elles sont
tributaires des choix politiques et
elles sont tributaires du climat
politique en france
non mais c'est ça mais bien sûr donc
donc du climat politique et des deux de
ce que deux du gouvernement qui est qui
est instaurée donc forcément politique
et sport ces îles sont directement liés
ils sont comptables de compatibilité
entre d'invitation
ils sont indissociables parce qu'ils
sont pieds et poings liés
la politique la politique d'un pays aura
un effet sur la politique sportive aie
aie aie aie en plus et alors là c'est
pas c'est plutôt social mais on sait
bien que la réussite de nos sportifs
pour ça que nous je pense que nos
sportifs sont eux aussi quelque part des
acteurs politiques dans le sens où il
nous guérissent la société par leur
réussite
on a mis fallait voir le ca a été
effectivement éphémère donc peut-être un
placebo mais la réussite à 98 de
l'équipe de france a créé quand même une
une un rassemblement social qui a été
sans pareil en france donc l'appareil
nos sportifs sont aussi je pense quand
ils sont d'une d'une envergure
internationale aussi importante des
acteurs sociaux si tu prêt pour le
combat pour la coupe du monde deux ans
que c'était vrai pour d'autres sports
mais aussi ce niveau là est il donc par
définition le drapeau et puis et puis
c'est cette communion c'est toujours
pareil on en vient des éléments de
communion et quand il ya du monde baiia
du politique royale du monde ya du
pognon et de la politique pour ne pas
dire autre chose
est ce qu'on doit se cacher mustapha
alors se cacher quand on supporte un
club par exemple là on la lui philippe
benassaya qui est supporter du psg et de
l'équipe de france
est-ce qu'il doit se cacher faut jamais
se cacher de rien faute nature des
galeries dans par exemple emmanuel
macron qui est un exemple ça ne joue pas
des tours ça lui joue des tours de toute
façon il aurait été pro marsa plus pro
psg ça leur a joué des tours de notre
manière de quémander faut se cacher de
rien il faut être nature
il veut supporter le vote l'om ce qui
l'a aidé c'est justement d'assurer c'est
un pote entre courants ses meilleurs au
monde mais seulement je préfère y a pas
à se cacher de rien un moment donné il
est présent de la république dans son
rôle de président la république c'est
l'équipe de france qui doit supporter
voir qui doit entretenir cette fois-ci
politique sportive par le biais d'un
ministère et par rapport au financement
et par rapport à la vision qu'on a du
sport pour un pays mais il n'a pas à se
cacher d'une relation personnelle qu'ils
avaient avant et qu'il aura probablement
après c'est un cdd un présent la
république donc on l'a vu supporter
marseille avant il veut supportera après
il mais il met pas en il met pas entre
parenthèses
non faut se cacher leurs yeux simplement
il est dans son rôle donc l'objet
présent la république c'est la france il
peut pas y avoir des tensions peut-être
avec certains colistiers
mais quand on quand on veut quand on
veut tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la
rage de toute façon ma quand ceux qui
l'aiment pas disent je comprends pas
qu'ils supportent de marseille
donc ils l'auraient détester pour
d'autres choses par le bon raisonnement
il a faim c'est aussi un être humain
donc il a des préférences et ils servent
vraiment sûr sûr sûr le fait d'afficher
un peu dé préférence et c'est aussi je
rejoins un peu l'idée de
en démontrant sa ils essaient aussi un
peu de s'attirer une espèce de sympathie
alors après servir de toute façon
choisie en mode cloud
il prend le psg c'est pareil mais à l
inverse donc à un moment donné sarkozy
qui était fan du psg président après
cette proposition qu'ils soient fans de
l'équipe de france
et voilà ce week end de france peut pas
parce que le mr parle ça qui trouvera
autre chose donc et c'est les gens qui
font de la politique
le cacher selon pierre chevalier non
parce que je pense que je pense que
l'histoire part au départ d'une d'une
image volée de campagne où il est
justement il parle d y parle des
résultats assez crûment ce genre café du
commerce comme on pourra en parler ici
et il parle il parle de marseille qui en
a pris 2 à monaco et il y avait deux
solutions c'est soit soit il est celle
des droits bientôt peut-être soit il
essayait d'étouffer la faire soit ils
assumer et là pour le coup je pense que
je pense que ça puisse servir un peu son
image pas pour les parisiens bien sûr
mais ça a servi son image parce qu'il a
actionnés d'être fan supporter que peut
il supporter marseillais tu fais pas
pour lui c'est super marseille on va pas
voter pour lui c'est les gens qui font
de la politique justement c'est que idy
ça donc je veux pas pour les jeux tu
auras pas à voter pour lui donc toute
façon donc c'est en ça que je dis faut
pas que la politique s'immisce dans le
sport vous êtes d'accord avec moi je
pense que ça n'a pas d'effet et que le
sait c'est trop petite échelle n'y a pas
de rapports ça veut dire qu'il faut tout
c'est son discours ses préférences donc
je déteste ces jeunes arabes la dg
valises et j'aime réalité c'est pour
avoir un maximum de votes en nature
moment donné
une période où il ya la coupe du monde
dont quelque part on est dans un thème
foot c'est un peu normal enfin ça peut
tout à fait se expliqué qu'il exprime
une préférence sur un club ou un autre
il a peut-être un truc sur son facebook
depuis longtemps où il a les drapeaux de
marseille c'est à l'église on imagine
surtout que tout différend dans le
calcul qui avait déjà beaucoup de
calculs à la campagne dans la campagne
présidentielle
la lasure je t'aide pas si c'est ce qui
est spontané mais est ce qu'au niveau
local il faut se cacher ce que l'on
parle du niveau national de macron elle
s'intéresse qu'au niveau local on doit
se cacher peut-être un peu plus qu'au
niveau national proximité avec les gens
encore plus là bas moi je suis fan de
trappes
je suis sûre trappe ça me pose aucun
problème de parler de mon équipe donc
vous pouvez pas la mairie de femmes ah
bah non je viens de dire l'inversé
thaler il est hors de question de
prendre par définition un club de foot
pour faire ma petite
si à un moment donné dans un parcours
personnel au bout par exemple prend dans
mon cas je suis visé on est bien
d'accord
au bout de quatorze ans de de sérieuses
étaient du coup je me suis attaché à
l'objet foot pas de politique pas de
partis pas de meeting rien dans mon
parcours personnel j'aurais moi envie
citoyens de faire de la politique c'est
possible pour tout le monde est donc
possible pour moi
il faudra que je mette en retrait total
du club de foot et surtout pas ares pour
les spas merger gens à jamais de la vie
sans sexe ne faut pas mélanger
mais mes jambes et c'est là où un moment
donné j'ai dit il ya beaucoup trop de
gens qui prennent des clubs amateurs et
qui pourrissent le monde amateur
justement parce qu'il ya des intérêts
personnes soit pour prendre faire de la
politique
soit pour faire du business
en tant qu'équipementier je crois
pouvoir dire et ça se vérifie facilement
que je n'ai pas fait de politique mieux
à chaque fois qu'il y ait des campagnes
électorales et municipales en
particulier j'ai demandé à tous et tous
les gens qui faisaient la politique qui
étaient dans des parties de son extrait
de s'extraire du club pendant la période
électorale et laisser le club tranquille
donc si je devais en faire clairement je
l'annoncerai très tôt je mettrai en
retrait de d'uccle a bien su le
reprendre les termes de raul c'est dire
que le politique et sport sont liés pas
forcément compatibles mais de tout ce
sont intimement liés quand il s'agit de
ses bosses et de faire briller de faire
briller la haute mer mais finalement
c'est un verre litige et c'est pour ça
que j'ai c'est la question la question
est est ce que j'ai dit elle
mais c'est pour faire de la politique
politicienne ou partisane alors c'est
compliqué en tout cas ne fait pas ça
mais j'ai été président et c'est
vraiment son cadre privé j'étais
président et avec tom il supporte
plaisent toujours présidence est facile
d'honneur et donneur de leçon je le dis
carrément il ya une politique sportive
dire que ont conduit pas un club
n'importe comment il ya des politiques
ce parti de la même façon
de la même façon la mairie suit le sport
dans sa commune donc il ya une politique
sportive de la commune de la même façon
le retrouve au niveau national donc
politique sportive police max et lili
désolé et honteux par les fusées pas
parler football est un message mais oui
il y en a marre d'entendre tout ce qu'on
dit sur l'équipe de france un moment
donné on s'est qualifiés peu importe si
on a pris du plaisir à regarder massy a
pas eu des sombreros ci a pas idée
reprise de volée 6 était insipide
on est en huitièmes ça commence
maintenant ce samedi 16h contre
l'argentine
c'est la fin de cette émission se
retrouvent le jeudi à 12 juillet pour la
dernière émission de l'année on va
terminer par une citation de l'ancien
footballeur est maintenant entraîneur
luis fernandez le champion tire les
leçons du passé concrétise le présent et
pense au futur
je vous laisse méditer sur cette phrase
rendez vous le jeudi 12 juillet à
bientôt sur tv 78 c'est connu et des
philosophes
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]